[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
as
is chris mannix he's the senior nba
writer for sports illustrated he joins
us on the program
what would the storyline be today if
phoenix had won last night chris
ooh referees gone wild
would have to be have to be right i mean
that was one of the more
egregious non-calls that i've ever seen
and the explanation
uh to the pool reporter afterwards is
probably worse
i mean to paraphrase it it was
you know i i thought there was a clean
swipe
which there wasn't that i saw the hand
on the back which there was
i mean dan this it's hard not to look at
that play
and not see a referee that was
determined to keep devin booker in the
game yeah he had five fouls
so if they had if phoenix had won that
game
all we would be talking about today
would be a referee conspiracy theory
to make for the sons to win so what
should the headline be today
you know to me it's the ascent of chris
middleton continues
like i was writing this last night like
there was a couple of years ago when
chris middleton made his first all-star
team
when you looked at chris middleton and
he said all right
we'll put him on the all-star team but
it's mostly because
the bucks are really good and you can't
have
just one all-star on a team that in
mid-season
is sitting at or near the top of the
conference he almost benefited from the
success
of the bucks but you know he's had some
good finals games game one
was his best prior to game four but
that 40 point performance in game four i
think that really cemented chris
middleton
as a true top 20 type player
uh in this league so his his
breakthrough
to me was the biggest story of that game
for those who didn't see the greek
freaks block on deandre ayton
you being a wordsmith how would you
describe it
uh unique
you know what lebron did in 2016 was
remarkable like the the sheer
athleticism
of lebron to get back and block iguodala
was remarkable i don't know that there's
any player
in league history that can do
what giannis did on that play to be
defending
the the the ball handler on the screen
devin booker
and then have the athleticism and
instincts to get
back and then have the strength
and timing to block a seven
footer at the rim i don't i don't know i
can't think of too many guys that could
do it like
i guess you go all the way back in time
and think of bill russell one of the
great defensive players in nba history
but players in that day weren't anywhere
near as athletic
as the players of today so i that's the
kind of block like we might
see and frankly lebron's done it
multiple times we have seen it we might
see it a block like lebrons again
i don't know that we ever see a blocked
shot in that situation
like giannis two things that stood out
you got to reflect back on
the injury that he suffered yeah and
you got to factor that in the other
thing is i think
just the thought of trying to block it
fascinated me
not that he blocked it just that he was
going to think about
going up to block it and then like you
would go okay i'll just let him have
that slam dunk
that to me was that's the fascinating
part of it you just go
oh my god oh my you know like he's going
up to block oh he did block it
and dame lillard tweeted in real time he
said
giannis just won the game and you know
there was a little over a minute to go
so i give him credit
that what that did to the rest you know
the next
90 seconds he i mean he took away
phoenix you know whatever it was he took
it away in that one
one play yeah it was about 114 left to
play
and if ayton converts that dunk it's a
tie game and all of a sudden phoenix's
got a little bit of momentum there they
get one stop
and you know devin booker chris paul
whoever can erase any of the issues
of of the previous quarter i'm with you
the like i think rudy gobert
is the best defensive player in the game
you know fundamentally day to day
i think gobert deserved that defensive
player of the year there's no way
gobert even considers blocking that shot
doesn't get back there
in time to do something like that guys
like giannis and lebron
have such confidence in in their
athleticism and in their timing and all
the things that make them so physically
great
that they might be the only two players
in the league that would believe
that on that play they can finish it
with a blocked shot
chris manick sports illustrated nba
senior writer should we be concerned
about chris paul if you're a phoenix
suns fan
i think a little bit um and not because
i think there's anything wrong with
chris paul i think that drew holidays
had his number
the last couple of games and you know
you go back to game three
and paul's numbers were fine i think he
was eight to 14 19 points nine assists i
mean good game but not
it wasn't the takeover type games he's
had in the previous two games and in
previous series
of these playoffs holliday did something
in that game three
picking chris paul up at about three
quarter court or more
and i think that put a lot of strain on
chris paul i mean holliday
is a big long sturdy defender i mean
he's really good
at that position i think the pressure
he's put on chris paul
has generated some fatigue in him at
this point and if you're milwaukee
you've got to feel like that matchup
is is working for you so i don't know
that it's an adjustment chris paul
necessarily can make but if i'm monty
williams
one of the things i'm doing going into
game five
is finding a way whether it's through
early screens bulb movement
of getting drew holiday off chris paul
to get him back into a rhythm
uh any update on the ben simmons trade
market
not really um you know
the sixers i think we talked about this
specifically but
predictably are valuing ben simmons like
he's
basically like the playoffs last year
this year didn't happen like that he is
the all-star two-time all-star defense
highly rated defensive player elite guy
and from what i was told by one team
that talked to philadelphia
they're not looking to take any steps
back like they want
dollar for dollar value or better on
ben simmons in a trade because
justifiably i mean philly looks at
itself and says look we got mb
at the peak of his powers tobias harris
had a great year we got enough shooting
to help us win they don't want to trade
for you know
younger players and draft picks they
want a guy back in return
that will help them win a championship
next season and honestly
even though even though houston or
philadelphia is really able to deal with
29 other teams
because of ben simmons contract i'm not
sure that's
available to them right now and i've
said this to you before and it bears
repeating
if i'm philadelphia i'm just circling
portland like a vulture i'm just even if
it takes you
into next season like i want to see what
the portland trailblazers do
with damien lillard and cj mccollum
because
it feels to me dan like portland is like
one 11 and 15 start from saying you know
what screw this
we're not good we got to blow this thing
up we got to take advantage
of our stars having good contracts to
trade
while we can i i if i'm if i'm daryl
morey
i'd hate to deal ben simmons and then
get to december
and see portland put like an auction
sign in front of their their office and
say we're open for business
thank you chris as always safe travels
you got it dan
chris mannix senior writer for sports
illustrated covering the nba finals